[Music]
contingent or to demonic 52 Rafael I
don't have access to the damaged area
there were you John
[Music]
at only 24 years old GFX today is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
completely on his own no quest system
mor MVP to Curitiba Kazuto Damona
Don Lemon king about us Pedroia second
sir the chaplain T the uncle kept
intestine where gemser is you can
actually take a million stars they also
charged in Manila he left his home in
France two and a half years ago to begin
his journey Geneva Devon d'espagne
credited for Sagada as energy liquid
oxygen in action evil okay I'm oh yeah
question evil guano news restiano
accredited Conicelli pathogen OS
non-profit electrons each vari mean on
pacific salud para dormir America face
roll voyage Eva stamina Kosovo to
account shampoo party green on socialism
because any medium Volvo to vessel but
the cruiser myself a gentleman
siamo super although if the navigating
alone his stamina mike lee companion que
la cabeza unique survey Darryl Kuehl a
de más de bomba to know Peter Anthony
okay Dex pero una vida a person Ellis
Fischel new potato novo Monica Cuba okay
Larry Eskimo Joe provider mobile that
Vienna is all about you German upon you
done such dr. Lewton Dirac an official s
from the Greek Muni only cure you in
with Alaska Montes pest problems
totally
Zambia Offit not to be non-experience
approach et à côté de sol la si vamos a
hacer esto SE TV an escape in on a gas
dumansky to Perico Ramon Sakina me
second entry success mm dynamo memos
resident remember to appear totally
focused on the data Excel alumna a
vulture is virtual Rossi Kelly Munich
upon Yana Illinois welcome Oscar right
blind horse that's a little difference
but to me it don't make much difference
he's pretty good friends he just tickled
to death to be rode
I think he knows that he's got eyes and
and he just jumped up and down and runs
and really likes to go out my name is
Roderick Olson I'm soldier Grove
Wisconsin I have always had a few horses
matter of fact quite a few of them well
we got Jackson about 21 years ago about
ten years ago that we noticed it is
going blind and it was fired we can find
I would nothing we can do about it most
old horse dealers or fire ladies did get
rid of the horse but I figured I can
keep I'd like to stick around a while
longer so if I went blind oh I hope they
keep me around a while I didn't figure
he were useless
he does everything you want by the feel
of the range he's a little different
riding than a regular horse he's careful
when he's running you know he ain't sure
where his feets going to go or what
their front of him but he didn't just
quit because he got blind he's trying to
do things so he can take care of himself
he trusts me to writing I think he just
figures it man I can see now I got eyes
I can do things that I wanted to do for
a long time he watched it run he's fun
for me to ride we go all over the hills
down the canyons in the water everywhere
that any other or can go he does just
fine he must trust me and well I trust
him oh it's kind of a buddy anyhow being
friends with a horse that's a I don't
last the way I'd been with me all my
life
[Music]
if sheep are everything they're my
employees they're my co-workers they're
my livelihood I'm very much bonded to my
animals and I hope they're bonded to
help they enjoy working with me as much
as that one joy working with them
[Music]
my name is Zach Richardson and I'm an
urban shepherd
I saw myself an urban shepherd because I
guess technically I am a shepherd one
who tends a flock of sheep but most of
my projects are in the city urban
grazing is the strategic use of sheep to
manage overgrown landscapes in an urban
context right now I have a total of 60
used or female sheep sheep will eat just
about everything this site has that
about every invasive species that's
common in Middle Tennessee you know
euonymus English ivy
privet honeysuckle Japanese honeysuckle
Tree of Heaven but they'll eat all of
them let's say you have an overgrown
piece of property you call me and you
tell me exactly the areas that you're
targeting and then we load up some sheep
on a trailer bring you a modest flock
and they stay on site until the job is
completed dougie is the most important
component to my business more important
than my truck he's more important than
my trailer almost more important than
the Sheep his job is a border collie
instinctively is to gather the sheep and
he loves doing it you could throw a
junior whopper at Emily's working he
wouldn't care he just wants to keep
working that'll do here duck nada
this is not a new concept and a moving
shoot to clear land here in the city
we've forgotten that this is even
possible there's an option deep down in
all of us somewhere to want to watch
animals do what they do we just kind of
been removed from it there are a few to
admit just watch the shoe p1 core trait
in every dog is its ever forgiving
nature that's probably the most valuable
thing in a dog and it's also its biggest
pitfall because we have dogs here who've
been horribly hurt by human beings
and yet all I wanted was find somebody
else to look around the world strayed
mutts and Street dogs are victims of
stigma in Costa Rica via battle is
trying to change that story she runs the
territorio de Poitiers it's a lush haven
for stray dogs either be adopted or to
live out the rest of their days
territories of what this stands for land
of the month my name is Leah battle
better known as crazy dog lady is I
started very 30 as I watch this
partly because I've always loved animals
all animals but it wasn't in my plans it
wasn't like I set out to do this the
need for this I think all over the world
is because it refused stigma around a
dog that doesn't have a breed they let
smut wander on the feed or they'll
actually toss them on the streets
because they're not breed dogs the
solution isn't euthanizing a dog's the
solution is make sure it's not born in
the first place once it's here do
something good for it to find a home or
if not at least offer him a place where
you can be in peace and happy keeping
territorial up and running is no easy
feat they eat $500 a day in food alone
leah has to work a full-time job to keep
all the dogs fed and healthy the reso
deal stays about partly through miracles
I think keeping this afloat is a huge
task it's a labor of love you can't pay
someone to care for an animal truly to
remember their name to be gentle for
them while this place is a dog heaven
nothing beats getting adopted by a
loving family I'd say it's like pizza
kindergarten they love their friends at
school but oh they all want to go home
to mom and
[Music]
monkeys definitely feed off of your
feelings they know when you're feeling
down or when you're feeling funny it's
kind of an urban legend people out there
training monkeys to help people with
disabilities but that really happens I
have my monkey Kiki fort Angus in 2005
Irishman I injured xi1 xi2 spinal cord
with a prank
I can move a really angel or I can talk
they are tomorrow our goal is to train
and place capuchin monkeys with people
living with mobility impairments the
program that start really as an
experiment say we can train a dog to
help somebody who has visual impairments
perhaps we can train a primate to be the
hands for somebody who has had a spinal
cord injury we provide our monkeys at no
charge to our recipients all of our
monkeys are born into our programs
typically a monkey will spend about 3 to
5 years at the monkey college learning
tasks whether that's fetching a phone or
remote control off the floor helping
somebody get something to drink even
something as complicated as slipping the
pages of a book the monkeys do we react
as hands and give them that level of
independence back you can imagine having
a spinal cord injury and all of a sudden
you have a monkey that's sitting on your
shoulder you can finally feel that touch
to have a with that monkey there is an
incredible bonding experience we can
move take your ottoman now as a lot of
motion
for the love companionship cases were my
thing you know this is a five pound
animal die is extraordinarily helpful
and brings joy to my life
[Music]